hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in section 4
his essay the will to believe William
James will set out what he calls by the
title of that section the thesis of the
essay and it runs like this he says our
passional nature not only lawfully may
but must decide an option between
propositions whenever it is a genuine
option that cannot by its nature be
decided on intellectual grounds so what
are we talking about there he's saying
that when we don't have intellectual
grounds for deciding certain sorts of
options that is genuine options as he's
defined them a little bit earlier in the
work then our passional nature is not
only permitted to help us make that
decision we have to make that decision
along passional lines and we'll come
back to that in a moment because you
might say okay well what does that
actually mean this passional or is he's
going to call it also volitional or
wheeling nature you could also talk
about this in terms of effectivity and
it's connection with belief so if we
jump back further to the the beginning
of the previous section he talks about
this guy William Clifford and William
Clifford is in his famous essay as well
saying that we should never believe
anything unless we have evidence for it
and James says that's kind of a weird
position to take because we do that all
the time especially even scientists and
the people who are supposed to be the
most rational and even you as he's gonna
say a little bit later and even you
William Clifford believed things without
necessarily having you know perfect
reasons for doing so now there is some
truth to this he says that it is only
are already dead hypotheses that are
willing nature is unable to bring to
life again
but what has made them dead for us is
for the most part of previous action of
our willing nature of an antagonistic
kind that is we have decided now that
that's not true
and you know so for example the person
who has left a group who they belong to
and can no longer buy into their lies
and charlatans reor whatever else it's
going to be their ideology their
brainwashing right they've actually
decided on some level that they're not
going to believe what that group has to
say and sometimes they can swing to
another extreme where they'll disbelieve
any true facts that that group brings
forward so he says well what is this
willing nature what is what is this
comprised and again here we could talk
about effectivity or all sorts of other
things as well James here it's good to
remember - James is not only a
philosopher but also a psychologist so
he's got a lot fuller treatments of this
elsewhere but here in this essay he
distinguishes two things he says that
the Willing nature includes what he
calls deliberate Volition's as may have
set up habits of belief that we cannot
now escape from so deliberate Volition's
those are actually sort of a small
subset of Volition's where we sat down
and we weighed evidence or you know
decided what's the most prudent thing to
do and we made a decision and then
because of that those set up habits of
belief so generally this involves doing
it more than once so the habits of
belief now we cannot escape from at
least at this point in time we're sort
of stuck with them
and we can think about this in terms of
training we can think about this in
terms of education we could think about
this in terms of deep programming and
reprogramming and all of those sorts of
fairly deliberate at least mostly
conscious activities where we say yes
I'm gonna see things this way no I'm not
going to see things this way anymore but
it includes a lot more than that in this
willing nature he says it includes all
factors of belief and here James gives
us a non exhaustive list
largely organized I would say along
rhetorical lines this was in fact a
public address so this is not the
comprehensive list of all the possible
fat
of belief he's just giving us some
important examples here he says fear and
hope we could think of those as
fundamental types of activities right
typically we would contrast say hope and
despair but despair is sort of fear
intensified desire we might also place
under hope and we could think of other
emotions that play a role in there as
well
anger is a prime example joy sadness
excitement boredom all of those could
play a role within whether or not we we
believe things prejudice and passion
right there are many things on which we
have prejudices and he's going to give
some examples actually let's take a look
at some of the examples that he brings
up because some of them may not be all
that effective for us he says here in
this room we all believe in molecules
and the conservation of energy most of
us probably believe in that in democracy
and necessary progress democracy I think
most of us are for that although we may
not like the way democracy works in many
places necessary progress now we're
getting a little bit more sketchy in
Protestant Christianity and the duty of
fighting for the doctrine of the
immortal Monroe I think we can probably
say that that one for most of us is
definitely not among our prejudices the
doctrine of the immortal Monroe was the
Monroe Doctrine which said that the
United States would you know not allow
foreign intervention within Central or
South America with the idea being that
eventually the United States would
incorporate all of that within their
sphere of influence you know I don't
know that too many people even here in
America buy into that anymore as a
prejudice but we can say we have other
prejudices instead you know the
incredible amount of difficulties that
were winding up in in providing
something that most developed countries
have had for quite a while say universal
health care and the you know quandary
the that people are finding themselves
in
they can't wrap their head around the
government actually being able to do
that when it's done so routinely in so
many other places you know that's a
prejudice essentially right we could
talk about other prejudices of the
Americas but we can talk about
prejudices of other places as well
prejudices and passions right imitation
and partisanship there's many things
that we learn just by imitating other
people doing them you know there's a
great old joke about the line forming
and somebody gets in the line they ask
the person ahead of them hey what's this
line for and the other person says I
don't know but I saw that there was a
line so I figured it must be something
important so I lined up and it goes all
the way up to the front of the line and
nobody knows what the hell they're in
line for well that's that's imitation
taken to the extreme is it not but you
know some of it could be what Rene
Girard is called mimetic desire the
release of the new eyePHONE matters
because other people think it matters
and so now you get infected with that
feeling and you think I'd better get
there in line right partisanship can
play a major role we see this in our
divided electorate today where people
have taken it so far as to say that they
won't even consider dating in there in
some cases talking with somebody from
the other side and they are extremely
gullible when it comes to their favored
news sources circum pressure of our cast
and sets that's an interesting idea is
talking about background there our class
background right where we fit in in
society a good example of this is you
know we think about people and their
their mindsets that are produced by how
they grow up what options they see is
possible for them that actually makes
sense those are live options and what
our dead are set you know the people
that we we spend time with and so you
know he's got quite a few good examples
of that but I think we could think of
our own all of this is are willing
nature each of us carries around
an entire set of constellations of
effective points that we bear with us
from situation to situation adding a
little bit taking some away modifying a
bit here and there but never changing it
all at the same time except through
catastrophic and traumatic experiences
which even then are interpreted in light
of what we we bring to it now he says
that these passional tendencies and
Volition's a little bit down before that
he says our non intellectual nature does
influence our convictions there are
passional tendencies and Volition's some
of which run before and others which
come after belief and he says it's only
the latter those who come after that are
too late for the fair and they're not
too late when the previous passional
work has already been going in their
direction so even then they can be
incorporated into the mix he also talks
about this this tendency on most
people's part including he admits his
own for one's own reason especially
among that we used to probably should
say the people who are the biggest
advocates and shouters about reason
logic facts all that sort of stuff
they're typically satisfied with just a
few arguments that go in their favor
they often ignore the ones that don't
and they also we should point out here
tend to ignore the fact that things like
reason logic you know science
rationality these are equivocal terms
that require a lot of clarification so
you know mountain most people tend to be
happy with being provided a few
arguments so it doesn't shake their
intellectual boat to mix metaphors a
little bit and there's this wonderful
phrase that he has here faith in other
people's faith the idea that somebody
else found this convincing is often
enough to produce a belief on another
person's part I'll admit that that that
works for me as well you know I have a
limited time to read authors
and you know when I look at who I should
spend the time to read I often will see
what the people who I respect have to
say about that authors is it worth
checking them out
and I also look to see the people who I
think are jerks are stupid what they say
about that author they're blowing them
up and everyone's like oh you must read
this person I'm likely to say that's
probably not worth my time or maybe I'll
check it out but give it you know a
cursory glance rather than actually
digging into it like I would with say
William James who is worth reading right
so faith in other people's faith this is
a very interesting idea he also talks
about the faith in truth itself he says
our belief in truth itself that there is
a truth and that our minds in it are
made for each other
what is this but a passionate
affirmation of desire in which our
social system backs us up we want to
have a truth we want to believe our
experiments and studies and discussions
must put us in a continually better and
better position towards it and on this
line we agree to fight out our thinking
lives but if a pyro 'no skeptic asked us
how we can know all this can our logic
find a reply james says no it's just one
volition against another we are willing
to go in for a life upon a trust or
assumption which he for his part does
not care to make and he points out here
that we often disbelieve in facts and
theories now notice he doesn't just say
theories or explanations or
interpretations we often disbelieve in
facts things that are staring us in the
face that we have no use for and he
gives as an example of this three
different religious orientations William
Clifford's cosmic emotions find no use
for Christian feelings Huxley Beliebers
the bishops because there's no use for
sacra totalism in his scheme of life but
John Henry Newman on the other hand goes
over to Romanism that his Catholicism
and finds all sorts of reasons good for
staying there because the priestly
system is for him an organic need and
delight so he might say oh that's
religious people
then James targets the scientists and he
says why does so few scientists even
look at the evidence for telepathy
so-called sort of reading of minds or
communication at a distance he says
because they think as a leading
biologist want now dad once said to me
even if such a thing we're true
scientists ought to band together to
keep it suppressed and concealed it
would undo the uniformity of nature and
all sorts of things without without
which scientists cannot carry on their
pursuits but James says if this very man
had been shown something which is a
scientist he might do with telepathy
he might not only have examined the
evidence but found it good enough and
then James globalizes us this very law
which logicians would impose upon us is
based on nothing but their own natural
wish to exclude all elements for from
which they and their professional
quality as logicians can find no use so
what he's saying here is that dig deep
enough and you'll find that pretty much
every commitment of belief whatever
window-dressing or ever not just window
dressing but whatever deep apparatus of
reason and argument and evidence and
logic we bring to bear willing nature is
always driving it willing nature is
always there willing nature is always
involved so we come again to the
conclusion that he draws our passional
nature not only lawfully made but must
decide an option between propositions
whenever it is a genuine option that
cannot by its nature be decided on
intellectual grounds now notice what
this is saying if it can be decided on
intellectual grounds don't decide it on
the basis of our willing nature so don't
be sloppy don't be lazy don't simply
substitute feeling for fact as we might
say all right but when it comes down to
things where there is going to be
disagreement and controversy it's okay
to bring in our passional nature not
only is it okay in some cases we must
decide
that very basis so he says to say under
such circumstances do not decide believe
the question open that itself is a
passional decision just like deciding
yes or no and it's attended with the
same risk of losing the truth so this is
where the not just may but must comes in
there are going to be some issues some
questions on which during the course of
our lives we do have to declare
ourselves or we can decide not to but
that's also a declaration of some sort
and all of this is going to involve and
be based on to some extent our willing
or passionate nature
you